今日テーマの第2部でございます
どうすれば心の不安がなくなりますかということ
先月の話でもうまあ 不安というものは解説しながら
そのなくなる方法をそのまま教え説明いたしましたから
特別に今日は不安なくなる方法という特別なテーマにならなくたっても構いませんと思ってます
で まあ私は私が初期仏教から考えているところだけ説明いたしますが
それは現代皆様の生き方にはまあまあちょっと合わないところもあるかもしれません
現代 大変複雑な生き方なさってますから
そこら辺は話終わってから皆様集めて
この鈴木先生もいますから
この集めて皆様でこの信奉支援みたいな形で
自分なりのその その現代社会において複雑な問題どうしますかとかね
まあそこら辺お話しなさった方がよろしいと思います
あまり具体的なことを私にはあまり喋れませんので
それほど知識はないんです
で で この不安という問題はこの前申し上げましたように
このこの現代の人々によくあるようなもの
なんですね  なかなか言葉もないんですからね
パーリ語にも言葉はありませんし
で ですから もし経典に直接言葉があったならば
大変説明しやすいんだけどね
で 昔の世界であったのは
人間というのは まあやっぱり困ったり悩んだりしたことは認めているんですね
いつでも心の中で悩みということはありましたと
仏教用語で出てくるのは
この疑ということ 疑いの疑ですね
その疑いといえば なんか別に現代人が何か疑ってるわけじゃないんですね
疑ってるという疑いではなくて
あのカンカーというパーリの言葉で
KANKHA 最後の A は長い KANKHA カンカーで
まあ英語で言えばアンクサイティ
ANXIETY ANXIETY アンクサイティ
そんなようなものなんですね
だから現代的に言えば
それはここの不安とほぼ似ているんですね
違う言葉で言えば しっかりしない心の状態
心はしっかり明確になってない
だから その状態 もともともあるならば
もう生きることは大変なことになるんですよ
心はしっかりしていない
明確明晰ではない そうすると料理したっても無茶苦茶になっちゃうし
家の中も整理したっても
心は落ち着いてしっかりしていないと
それもまたうまくいかないし
会社に行って仕事をしてもうまくできるわけじゃないし
学校に行って勉強したっても
心落ち着いてないとしっかりしてないとできないんですね
ですから もともとそういう心理的な
そういう状態があるんだと
それはあるんだから 人は何やろうと失敗だらけでうまくいかない
問題がいろんな問題が出てくる
それでまた頭は混乱状態になっちゃって
どうしようか どうしようかと
で さらにさらに混乱が大きくなって
増えて増えていくんですね
で 明確にまた考え直してみましょう
もともと心がしっかりしていないガタガタ状態で
疑という専門用語は疑なんですけど
で 疑いがありまして アンクサイティというものがありまして
で パーリ語で言えばカンカー
ヴィチキッチャとかいろいろ専門用語がございますが
そういうものがありまして
しっかりしない 落ち着きがない
心はなんか明晰的ではない
その人が何をなさってもうまくはいかない
どこかでもうガタガタ
その残っちゃうんですね
中途半端になるんですね
丸くまとめて何かやることはもうきちんとOK
終わりました 終了しましたというふうな状態にはならないんです
で それ性格にも見えることたまにあるんですね
例えばこの 作家の方々とかね
で 必死で一生懸命作文を書いたりする
それを書くのはいいんだけど
部屋に行ってみたら まあむちゃくちゃ状態なんですね
で そこでまあ 吸い殻はもう 1キロぐらい溜まっているわ
もう部屋も10本 あっちこっち捨てているわ
散らかしているわ もう書いた紙はあっちこっちあるわとか
ものすごいもうもう見ていられない状態
混乱状態なんですね だからそれどういうことかというと
それぐらい自分の心の混乱と戦って戦って
やっと何かものを作りましたということなんですね
ですから それ書いて終わったところで
その人はものすごく疲れていて
精神的に肉体的にすごいガタガタ状態になっているんですね
そこで出版関係の人々は来て
強引にもう毎日来て もういじめてでもその書いてもらわなきゃ書いてくれないというふうな状態にもたまにありますし
それで作家の場合はものすごくパン状態になるということがあるんですね
何も書けなくなっちゃう
ストップ状態になっちゃう
で それでいてまた頑張って頑張って苦労して
また何とかして立ち上がるとか
でもまた同じことを繰り返したりする
そのパンク状態になることが
まあ我々にはまあよくあるんですね
そういう作家でなくても
普通の家庭の奥様たちにも
まあ心はパンク状態になっちゃって
もうどうにもならない
そういう状態になるということはよくあるんです
それはどういうことかというと
心はもともとしっかりしていない
明晰的ではないということ
疑いがあるんだと アンクライティというものがあるんだと
ガタガタ状態にいるんだということになるんです
ですから 繰り返し言ったのは同じことで
ですから我々がやっていることは複雑になります
それからもう全部ガタガタ状態になります
それからさらに心が弱くなってしまいますね
何か仕事をしたんだけど
うまくいってない 欠陥だらけで
自分でも納得いかない
もっとしっかりやりたいという気持ちはあるし
しっかりと自分の仕事をしたいと
でもやることは でもうまくそれで行かない
行かないんだから さらに心が悩んだりするし
そういうものは刀積み重ねて
この心は随分不安という状態に陥ってしまってしまうんです
ですから この解決方法はとても簡単なんです
この各仕事ごとに具体的に考えるんじゃなくて
どうすれば立派な文章を書けるかとか
どうすれば家庭の仕事は綺麗によくできますか？とかね
そういう知識を得ようとしたってもうキリがないんです
で 料理の上手な作り方とか
3 分で弁当の弁当 3 分でどのように作られますか？とかね
30 分で上手に掃除を終わる方法とかね
そういうふうに具体的に言っちゃうと
もうキリがないんです
洗濯物の上手な洗い方とかね
洗剤の上手な使い方とか
いくらでもありますよ
言うならば それは家の中の問題だったら
それで社会のことやら学校のことやら
会社のことやら そういういろいろ言ったら
まだいっぱいありますよ
キリがないんです だから
それは私の方で言ってほしいと思ったっても
私は別にそんな生活をしているわけでもないし
知るわけでもないし で
またキリがないんですね
ですから 我々に初期仏教から言えるのは
この論理的に法則を教えてあげる
その法則自体は全ての生命に当てはまるんだと
過去現在未来に関係なく
ですから その法則を身に付いて
それで自分の心を直してみようではないかということなんですね
ですから 解決方法は簡単なんですね
心明晰状態で守る いわゆる心は混乱しないようにする
それだけ ですから 自分で私は混乱状態にはなりませんと
私はしっかりと心の状態を守っておきますと
いつでも落ち着いていますと
何か混乱的なことに出会ったら
あ この場合は混乱しちゃったらうまくいかないんだと
だからしっかりと明晰に行動しますよと
と行動すれば それでもう不安というのは消えてしまうだろうと思いますよ
だいたいそれぐらいのことなんです
そんな大げさなことではないんです
いわゆるこういうこと
我々の人生で何があっても
何が起こるかわからないんですからね
何があっても 自分の心の中の状態
いつでも落ち着いて混乱しないように守ると
ヒステリーは起こさないんだと
その努力してほしい それぐらいわずかな努力もしないんだったら
もう私にはどうすることもできないんです
呪文はないんです もしそういうものがあるならば
初期仏教は呪文はないんだからね
大乗仏教にあるかもしれませんだけど
そちらのプロの方々に聞いてみてください
なんか心落ち着いてくれる呪文でも何かあるんですか？とか
で 具体的に言うならば
例えば自分の家の身内の一番親しい人が誰か亡くなったと
亡くなったと聞いた瞬間
いきなりパーッと混乱状態
東も右もわからない状態になってしまっちゃう
それで何もできるわけじゃないんです
ですから それ あ なるほど
こういうことになったんですかと
そういうことはどういうことかと
あ こういう人亡くなったんで
亡くなったということはどういうことですかと
じゃあ それから私がどうするべきかと
もう何のことなく自分に聞けば
そこでこうすればこうすればいいとわかってくるんです
そうではなくて 人間っていうのは何々さんが亡くなったんだよと電話が入ってきたところで
いきなりあ どうしよう
どうしようと それですごい混乱状態に陥ってしまっちゃう
どうしようと口先で言うだけでどうしようもないんですね
どうすることもその人にできないんですね
で 一つ何でしたっけ？もう不幸な出来事に出会ったところで
その不幸からどうすれば立ち直るかということじゃなくて
みんな他の人 また新しいトラブルを作って
トラブルの中でまたいっぱいトラブルが作っちゃって
もうどうしようもない状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
そうする必要ないんです
ちょっと自分の心をちょっと冷静に
守れば混乱しないようにちょっと気をつければ
それだけで問題は解決する
私は自分の例はあまり言いたくないんだけど
このかなり昔 あの この大学で仕事をしていた時代で
あの それ終わって 大学毎日ないんだから
終わってからだいたい暇がありましたから
その暇な時間でお坊さんたちに
特別に若い和尚たちに
まあ学校があります そこで教えていたんですね
で それで私にあまりそれそういったって毎日教える時間がないんだから
ある時間でもう徹底的にもう教えているんです
ですから みんな集めて
必死になって勉強聞いてるし
それで急に電話が入ってきたんですね
どういう電話かというと
自分の母がもうもうもう大変
もう今もうすごい大変だと
で もう遺跡もないんだと
で うちの人々はどうすることがわからなくて困って私に電話かけてきて
私は母の状態を前から知っていたんだから
聞いたところで ああ もう僕は考えたら
もう自分の母であろうと
もうそろそろもう終わりだろうと
で 僕は何のこと ああ そうですか
じゃあすぐ隣にお寺があります
お寺に行ってお坊さんに言ってくださいと
うちにうちに言ってくださいと
そのまま頼んでくださいと
電話をかけたのはお寺から電話をかけたんです
うちに電話がないんです
で 何のことなく 僕はああ
どうしよう どうしよう
じゃあそうですか じゃあすぐお坊さんの名前
そのお坊さんに言ってください
すぐ行って母にお経をあげるようにと
すぐ命令みたいに言われたら
はい わかりましたと それだけで
そしたら その場ですぐお坊さんもうちに行って
まあ母に最後にお経をあげて
祝福して いろいろ心を慰めるようなことをしてくれたんですね
それ終わっても また 30 分もなるとまた電話をかけてきて
もう母が亡くなったと
亡くなったけど 僕はあなた方
私は言ったことやりましたか？と
そしたら はいはい もうお坊さんすぐ行ってお経をあげてきて
もう今帰ったばっかしで
そこですぐそのまま亡くなったと
そこでどうせもう大変重病になっていて
がんになっていて だからもう亡くなることはもう決まってあって
最後に別に私は泣いたっても混乱したっても
何の意味もない 我々に仏教を信じているんだから
最後にできることは もう一番最後の瞬間で
お坊さんに会わせてあげて
心を安らかに 清らかに
もう喜びの心で最期を迎えさせてあげることなんですね
そこで亡くなったと聞かったところで
ああ そうですか はい わかりました
これから来ますからと
もう何もする必要ないんですよ
それだけ それで僕は何のことなくまた授業に戻って
授業が終わるまでやって
それでまあ終わりましたからと
でまあ じゃあちょっと用事がありますから
私は行きますよと もう誰にも言わないで
もう家に戻ったんですね
家に戻っ 家に戻る前に全部葬式の準備をもう
あるところに行って そこでその人々
男の葬儀をやっている人々相談して
そこで決めちゃって あんた方はこの時間にこういう場所に来なさいと
また他のところに行って
そういう必要なものをなんとかなんとか言って
またそれからお寺に行ってお寺のお坊さんたちを話して
まあいつやればいいんですかとかね
まあお坊さんたちの都合もありますから
それで結構お坊さんたち来るんだから
私は出家だから そういう関係で
ですから 私はあんまりたくさん来ちゃったら困りますよと
ですから すごく内緒で
まあすごく内緒でやりたいんだと
まあ分かりましたと言ったんだけど
結構お坊さんたちは 100人ぐらい来てしまったんだけど
で それで私は家に行ったのは
もうもうお寺からもう 5分ぐらいなんですね
お寺にも来て もう 30 分
40 分経った時なんです
で うちに行くと 僕の家に行ってやること何もない
もう全部用意して終わってるんです
何一つなく だから村だから全部人々にお願いしてやってもらわなくちゃいけない
もう現代社会とは大違いますから
で 泣くことも 心の中で悲しみとか
そんな暇がないんです
あれできなかった できなかったんではないかと
やっぱり亡くなる前に
ちょっと自分がいた方がいいんではないかとか
そういう暇がない 考える暇も
じゃあ私は母が大変だと思うと言われたところで
行った方がいいんではないかと皆様でも思うかもしれません
それ無理なんです 向こうの交通状態では 1時間半ぐらいかかっちゃうんですよ
ほんのちょっとの距離でも行くためには
とんでもない交通状態で
それでもう病気のことはきちんと僕は把握していたんだから
もう言われた状態から見ると
もう 10 分  15 分待つかもわからない
それだったら行く意味がない
その瞬間で決めるんですね
気持ちとしては 母が亡くなる時はそばにいてあげた方がいいという気持ちがあるんですよ
どうせ私が行っちゃったら
かなり口がうるさいんだから
もう結構元気になると思いますけど
でもそれは事実上不可能だから
それに悩んだり困ったりする必要はないと
だからそれ一つの例を言ったのは
大体自分のね そういうことになったら誰でもショックを受ける
でも心は明晰にあると
何もショックもないし
余計な悲しみもないし
その代わりに自分でやらなくちゃいけないことはとことんとことんやれるし
それで別にもうある面では良かったとと思えるんですね
自分では 自分でできることは全部精一杯やりました
よかったと それで悩むことは何も残らない
ですから 我々はそういうふうな
この明晰な心 常に持たなくちゃいけないんです
私がそんな例を言ったんだから
自分たちも じゃあ私たちも自分の母が亡くなる時
そういうそうしますと決めるのはバカバカらしいんだからね
ですから この不安のない状態を実況するためには
母が死ななくちゃいけなくなっちゃいますから
それ可哀想ですけど そういうことではなくて
我々は毎日毎日問題に出会う
問題がない瞬間がないんです
朝起きた時から寝る時まで問題
寝たところで寝られないとまた問題
あるいは悪い夢を見た時
またそこにも問題 寝た
寝ても問題なんですよ
なんか変な夢を見たんだけど
どういう夢かなとか それまた問題し
あるいは疲れて疲れすぎちゃって十分寝られないんだと
寝不足だと それまた問題
ですから 人間にっていうのは寝るまでではなくて
24時間問題なんですよ
それに困ってやろうと思っちゃったら
どれぐらい困ればいいんですかね
切りがないんですよね
でもみんなよくそれやって生きてるんだから
元気で それまた不思議なんですね
24時間混乱だらけで
24時間困って困って困り果てて
ストレスばっかり溜まっちゃって
それでも元気でいることは奇跡なんですね
そういうことで あの 何があろうとも
心だけ混乱しない状態に持ちましょうとときちんと覚えておいてください
心の明晰な状態と明晰な状態と言うかどうかは日本語がおかしいかもしれませんだけど
で このすごくクリアな心
椅子でも持ちましょうということだけなんですね
私たちにできるのは そこで現代人がものすごいおかしいことをなさっているんです
どういうことかというと
問題解決しようと 問題さえ解決すれば
私に困ることはないんだと
あれ すごいおかしいんです
問題解決するできますかね
じゃあ人生にはたった一つ
二つぐらい問題あるならば
まあ頑張ってもう何十年でも頑張ってそれを解決できるかもしれませんだけど
そんなことじゃないでしょうに
毎秒毎秒いろんな問題に出会うんだから
解決できるわけないんです
解決できないんです それで解決できても
それはもうしっかりした知識人に
知恵の人にしか解決できないんです
ですから 私たちは我々にはこのもう海
海みたいに限りなくある問題の量を解決しようというふうに
余計なことをしなくても結構
その代わりに海に落ちちゃってもいいんです
浮いてさえくれれば そうでしょ
海の水を全部なくすってところで歩いていきますと
冗談じゃないんです 海に落ちたって
落ちているならば まあ浮いてさえもらえば
もうなんとか命を助かる可能性はありますよ
波にでもぶつかって もう水の流れがありますね
それ 水の流れでもちょっと計算して
流れにでも入っていれば
まあどこかでも流れて
確実にどこかの陸の方に行くんですよ
泳げなくても でもそれに必要なのは 1週間でも浮いてることなんです
それぐらいは人間にできるんです
だから悩みの解決方法はそれなんです
初期仏教から言えば なかなか皆様にはそれほどなんか面白くない話かもしれませんだけど
でも面白く もっと具体的に
私の話が終わってから皆様ご相談なさって
パネルディスカッションでもなさってみてください
一応 論理的な状態はそういうことなんです
で 繰り返して申し上げますけど
問題一つ一つに当たってみて
それ解決してやる あれも解決してやるというのは無理なことで
不可能なことで じゃあ例を申し上げます
例えば夫婦の間に問題があるんだと
それで  二人で解決しない場合は誰かに相談するということもよくありますけど
相談する時も一人だけ来て相談するんですね
そうすると  せっかく本当に問題解決したくて相談するのはありがたいんだけど
これ一人で解決できるものじゃないんですね
それその一人の人にこうしなさい
ああしなさいと言ったっても
そううまくいかないんです
問題の原因は二人にもあるんだから
でも一同二人では来ない
我々二人がいつでも毎日喧嘩しているんだと
だから我々二人がどうすればいいかとカウンセラーのところに行って聞かない
ですから もうたとえ夫婦の間に解決にしたっても
この世の中ではもう終わりっこはないんです
やり方は良くないんだから
ね それで一人が来て 自分の問題を言う場合はどう言うんですかというと
いつでも悪いのは相手ですよと
悪いのは相手ですよと
こういうことをします
こういうことをしますという
そこで そこは事実であっても
例えばカウンセラーに来る側が
じゃあどうすればいいんですか？どうすることもできないんですね
そこで奥様が相談に乗ったならば
奥さんが旦那さんがこういうことはします
こういうことをします
こういうことをしますと言うでしょ
そして奥さんにやっぱりそれはいけないんだ
ですから 旦那さんはこういうことをしてはいけない
こういうことをしてはいけない
こういうことをしてはいけないんですよと言ってあげたっても
そうならないでしょうね
それはできるならば 奥さん随分前これやっていただいてるんだからね
あなたはこれやめてくださいと
だから人間っていうのはおかしいこと
こういうふうに問題解決しよう
解決しようとと思うんだけど
解決方法も知らないし
解決する このもうどうにもならない状態になっているんですね
そこで不安が生まれるでしょうし
だから必要なのはそんな問題解決じゃないんです
そんな状態で自分の心をきちんとしっかりと明晰に守っておけば
浮いていれば この海でうまくいくということなんです
そこで大体夫婦の間にまた戻りますけど
お互いに問題あると言った場合は
ほとんど性格の問題 そこで奥様が相談する場合は
本当のところは奥様が自分の性格は変えたくない
その代わりに旦那の性格を自分にぴったし合うように変えてほしい
そんなことできるんでしょうかね
奥様の設計図の通りに旦那の性格をもう書き直すと
それはできるわけないでしょうに
誰が決めるんですかね
そのある ある奥様が書いた人格設計図が正しいんだと
他の人から見れば それはとんでもない人格設計かもしれませんし
それでその相談する人も
自分の人格設計は絶対変えたくはないんですね
それだったら他の人も自分の性格だけは全然変えたくない
それだったらどうすればいいと思いますか？人間関係の問題解決するために
誰一人も自分の性格は変えたくない
私は私の性格でもうそれでいきますと
あんた方は変えてちょうだいと
それでその方々も 私はなんで私は変えなくちゃいけないんですかね
あんたは悪いんだから
あんた方変えてくださいと
そんなことでずーっと混乱だらけでもう終わるんですよね
だから私はもう言いたいのは
こんな問題解決しようって
そんなことやめましょうと
やめた方がいいんです
問題やらトラブルやらあってももういいやと
その代わりに物事を理解して
きちんとした心の状態だけ守ると
そうするとずっとスムーズに生きていられる
人類の問題っていうのは悩み
不安 作られた問題っていうのは昔から今までもありましたし
これからもあるし そんなものは解決できないんだから
仏教は解脱という概念を教えているんです
解脱しろと 逃げろと 海に落ちた人はどうすればいいんですか？逃げる
海から逃げるしか道ないでしょうに
海とは戦う必要ないんです
放っておいて輪廻転生から逃げればいいんです
猛獣がいっぱい自由に生きている
どこかサバンナみたいなところに自分がもう
参り込んだと その人は幸福で生きていたいと思うならば
どうすればいいんですか？片っ端から猛獣たちと戦うんですかね
象が来たら象と戦う ライオンが来たらライオンと戦う
クマが来たらクマと戦う
戦って倒す それで生きていられると思いますか
それよりはもう何とかしてこのサバンナを逃げた方がいいでしょうに
猛獣たちを放っておいて
それしか道がないんです
そこで我々に聞いたっても
この戦い方法 クマと戦い方法
ライオンと戦い方法とかね
戦いきれないよ それで希望するんですね
機関銃さえあればとかね
来ると戦わなくたっても
もうパチパチと撃ってみんな倒せるだろうと
あるいは頑固な もう猛獣に攻撃できないような何か家でもあればいいんではないかとか
そんなものあるんだったら
そんなサバンナにいる必要もないでしょうに
全部準備万全な状態で
そこで迷子になるわけじゃないでしょうに
それで人間というのは
この非合理的なところというのは
そういうところで 人生という生きるという
このこの森に参り込んじゃって
どこを見ても自分を攻撃する猛獣だらけで
猛獣でないと小さな毒蛇もいっぱいいたりとかね
毒蛇から猛獣から体を守ると
虫やら蚊やらいろんな病気を持っている
そういう小さな動物がいたりして
どう見たっても逃げられない
ところにいるんですよ
いて そこで準備万全な状態を欲しがっちゃうんですね
それだったらその森から逃げた方が何の準備も要りませんし
機関銃も要りませんし
頑固な建物も要りませんし
蚊除け虫除けの塗り薬も要りませんし
ですから 不安な状態から完璧に解決したいというならば
逃げろと ということ そう
逃げるのは逃げるまではきちんとしっかりと頭を使っていろいろ問題を避けなけりゃ
来るしか方法はないんです
問題にぶつかるんじゃなくて
ちょっと避ける その方が楽なんです
誰かが 例えば石でも自分の方向へすごい勢いで流したと
それはその石を捕ま捕まろうとする
それよりはちょっと顔体を避けた方が一番楽なんです
捕まろうとする場合は
自分が直接その流れ流す
流れてくるというんですか
その飛んでくる石に直接体を合わなくちゃいけない
それで手で捕まなくちゃいけない
失敗しちゃったらどうなるんですかと
体に当たって 大怪我する
手で捕まっても手も怪我すると
だから大きな怪我か小さい怪我で終わっちゃうんですね
よけれた場合は 何の技術も技もいらなくてうまくいくと
ですからまあ そういうふうな生き方さえあればよろしいではないかなと思います
あまりもこの抽象的でちょっとわかりにくいんですね
でも その言葉だけ覚えておいてください
問題っていうのは 人生の問題っていうのはまあ避けるもんだよと
で そこだけを覚えておけばね
解決したっても あまり解決にならないんです
例えば 旦那さんがアル中だと
なんとかしてほしい それは明確にね
アル中は良くないと それで一生懸命そこをいろいろして解決すると
そのそもそもアル中になった人は何か問題を持ってるんですね
だからアル中になったと
そこでアル中をやめたのはいいんだけど
他のことにいっちゃう
競馬やら何かそういうことに凝ってしまっちゃうとか
で またあるんですから
そうするとそれは何とかしようという風になっちゃうんです
で 終わりがないんです
そういうことで 一番大事なのは何でしょうかというと
心のこのきちんとした状態
混乱のない状態 明晰な状態
落ち着いた状態 落ち着いた状態あればこういうことできるんです
問題は見える あ こういう問題かと見える
見えたところで これは一生治らないんだとわかる
あ この問題は何とかすれば治るんだと見える
あ この問題はあまりつまらなくて
別にいいんじゃないかと見える
そういうふうに問題をカテゴライゼーションできるんです
それでもう一生治らない
可愛い解決方法もない問題の場合は
もうまあ避けて生きていきましょうと
解決方法できるんだというわかった問題には
もうきちんと解決方法をすると
そんな大したことはないと思うものは
もう大したことないと思う
今思い浮かんだのは ある
アメリカである自分の国のお坊さんに相談に乗った
この ヨーロッパ人の奥さんがこう言ったみたいですね
もう離婚を考えているんだと
ずっと悩んでないんで
旦那のこと ですから どうすればいいんだと
そこで仏教というのは明晰に物事を質問したり聞いたりすることだから
そのお坊さんもいちいち結婚して何年ですか？とかね
なぜその人と結婚したんですか？とかね
その人の何に惹かれたんですか？とかね
そういうふうに聞いたそうで
そこでしっかりと捕まってね
こういうことで こういうことで
その人に気になって 一つ気になって
気に入って 一緒になった
それで何年かもずっと一緒にいたんだと
そこで嫌になって 何年かどうかね
今 離婚したいところまで嫌になっているんだから
そこで質問してして 最後にお坊さん捕まったのはこういう問題だそうですね
その旦那が夜起きて 冷蔵庫を開けて食べるんだそうです
普通 ご飯食べて寝るでしょ
寝て一旦起きたら夜真夜中とところでまた起きて
また冷蔵庫を開けて 冷蔵庫にあるものを取って食べてまた戻って寝ると
そこを気に入らないんですね
そこを気に入らないところで
もう頭混乱状態でいろんなことを妄想するでしょ
なんて行儀の悪い男かと
もうみんなしっかり食べたのに
またもう品格はなくて
冷蔵庫を開けてそれあるものをあちこち取り出したりして食べたりとかね
どうせ男のやり方だから
取ったものはそのまんまでとかね
またあるかもしれませんし
そこは奥様がちゃんと整理しているんだったら
あっち中のものを前に出したり
またあっちこっち状態にするかした可能性もあるし
それまた気に入らない
腹が立ったりする それでストレス溜まるでしょ
それで毎日毎日それで溜まっちゃって
この男とは一緒にはいられないということになっているんですね
そこでそのお坊さんが明確に問題だけ取ってみて
じゃあ問題っていうのは
その夜食べることだけでしょうと
ってなって それででも相談しているのは誰だと
奥さんでしょうに ですから
やっぱり旦那は夜起きて食べてはいけませんという命令を出しても
そこに旦那がいないでしょうに
あなたは行って自分の旦那に言いなさいと
行ったっても これはそれ言って済むならば
前もって奥さん自分で言えばいいのにね
そんな初めて見た日で言った方が良かったのに
それは問題の方法じゃないんで
それであのお坊さんこう言ったそうですね
いいんじゃないんですかね
すごい元気な旦那がいて
すごく食欲があってね
元気な旦那がいて良かったんではないかと
別に豊かな人だからね
夜食べたんだからといって
食べ物がなくなっちゃって困ったりということは
アメリカでまずないんだからね
アメリカ人の冷蔵かけちゃったら
3ヶ月間分の食料はいつでもありますからね
そういう問題はないし
ですから まあ食欲 ちゃんと食欲いっぱいあって
元気な男が旦那になって良かったんではないかと
言われたら まあただそれだけ
その問題は解決したんだそうですね
もうどこかわかりませんだけど
ですから このそれぐらいつまらないことで
我々は心さえ明晰じゃないんだから
膨大な問題まで大きくなる
そこで二人は喧嘩するかもしれませんだけど
はっきり言って何で喧嘩してるかとわからないんですね
ですから 一番大事なのは明晰な心があること
そうすると この人のこういう性格は嫌ですよときちんと見える
その性格は直れるものか
直せないものかとまた見える
見えたら直せるものだったら
そんなつまらないことやめた方がいいよと言ってあげればそれで終わるし
これはいくら頑張っても直らないんだと
性格だからと思っちゃえば
それと付き合えばいいし
そういうこと あまりこの人生について悩んだり困ったりする必要ないんですね
ですから 僕はあまり不安という
このすごい大雑把な わかりにくい状態というよりは
もっと具体的なところに持っていきましたけど
あの 人間にはいろいろ悩み
困り 悩んだり 困ったりするいろいろトラブル
問題があるということで
そこで心明晰じゃないんだから
すごくこの不安という
なんかもうもうした状態が生まれてきますからね
じゃあ 大体まあそれぐらいで人生はなんとかいくだろうと思いますよ
それからまあ ちょっとまあ細かい細かい
ことを考えてみましょう
で なぜ不安が生まれるかと
どうすればいいかと で
皆さんも聞きたがっているのは
やっぱりなんとか不安だということなんですね
なんとか不安ですよと
これ なんとか不安というのは全然治らないんです
それ全然治らないだけじゃなくて
このなんとか不安だとわけもわからないんだという不安は一番恐ろしいんです
治らないというならば
それで構いません だけど
それは一番恐ろしいんです
例えば 自分やっている商売
社会の状況が変わっちゃって
もう辞めなくちゃいけない人になったと
まあわかりやすく言えば
いろんなところで この小さなこの大きな会社が下請け下請けにして
このいろんな家庭でいろんな部品とかいろんなものを作って生活している方々がいるんですね
で まあ名前はでっかい会社なんです
結局下請け行って下請け行って
また行って また行って
もう何段階かわからないほど
で 最終的に誰かがもう自分の家でもう何かものを作っていて
で そこでこの会社から作るものは取ってもらわなきゃ
その人々には食べていられない
そこで急に会社がこの経費削減というなんとかということで
まあ自動化しましたと一部を
それでもう明日からはあなた方の品物は要りませんと言われたら
もう当然ずっと自分がやってきた仕事はそれで終わりでしょうに
それからどのように生きていらればわからない
あるいはしっかり仕事をしようと
1000万  2000万円で何か機械も買ったかもしれませんし
それ借金で それでも会社がもうものはもうもう要りませんと言われたら
もう大変なことなんですね
その時は本当に困るんでしょうね
その場合は でも その場合はなんとか不安という状態じゃないんです
しっかりと不安だと なんとか不安じゃないんです
しっかりと不安だと これからの将来は仕事なくなったと
また同じく仕事に戻ってくる可能性もないんだと
このしっかりした不安というのは
私は言うのはそれほど問題じゃないんです
なぜならば 不安は明確で
仕事は終わったということは明確だから
じゃあこれからどういうことをして食べていければいいかとと考えればいいんです
借金で買った品物はもうどんどんとあっちこっち売ったりして
自分も人を雇っていたならば
みんなもう他のどこかで仕事してくださいと
もう解散しちゃって 自分もどこかで他の仕事を探せばそこで問題は終わっちゃうんですよ
この会社は 20年やってきたんだから
なんとか会社を守らなくちゃいけないという
無意味なお話は要りません
ですから しっかりした不安にはしっかりした答えが出てくるんです
大体どこか答えが必ずあるはずなんですよ
問題はこういうしっかりした不安ではなくて
もうなんとか不安なんですね
なんとか不安だから これは原因ないんだから消えない
消えないだけじゃなくて
不安だけは一人勝手に膨張して
その人の人生はもう台無しにしてしまうんだ
そこのとこをちょっと考えてみましょう
このなんとか不安ってなんですか？と
このなんとか精神的な不安が生まれるのは
まあまず私に言えるのは頭が悪いんでしょう
それだけのことだと思います
で あの 頭が悪いっていうのは
この一番頭の悪くなる方は勉強することなんです
現代人が勉強すると頭が悪くなるんです
この現代人の勉強っていうのは
このとにかく情報を積み込む
頭の中にいろんな知識を積み込む
何のために積み込むか
全然そういうことじゃなくて
ただ単に情報知識を積み込む
そこで結局何もわかってないし
何も知らないとも言えないんですね
例えば もう体のことをちょっとがんになったよと言われたら
がんについていくらかは知っている
別にがんの専門家でもプロでも何でもないんです
あっちこっちくだらない新聞とか雑誌とかなんとか読んで
もうなんとか知識がある
それで強烈に不安が生まれている
この大雑把に入った知識だから
恐ろしいことやら恐ろしくないことやら
がんについてこういう治療があったということから
レーザー光線でがんなんかはきれいに取れたんですよというちょっとした記事やら
ぐらいの癌だったら もう何のことなく治せるんですよという記事やら
これぐらい癌にはもう全くもう何も治療法なくて
すごい苦しんで死にますよという知識
そういうもうもうなんか散漫ですね
知識の そういうものを積み込んでいて
それで癌だと聞いたところで
あれはもう出てきて もうすごい問題が現れてくる
他の問題についてあっても同じこと
経済状態を考えようと思っちゃったら
もう日本の経済はこうだこうだ
アメリカのはああだこうだとか
ヨーロッパのはああだこうだとか
もうあっちこっちこの知識残飯が頭に入ってるんですね
それ働かせちゃって すごい新しい問題が生まれてくる
とにかくややこしいのは
何かしゃべろうとすると
なんとか知ってるんですね
そのことについて 例えば私は心理学のことをしゃべろうと思っちゃうと
あっちこっちユングがこう言ったとかね
もう何々人がこう言ったとか
夢の場合はこうこうだとか
精神分析とかああだこうだとかね
二重人格ってこういうこういうこと
もう何とか知ってるんですよ
だからどうにもならないんですね
説明してもしても ただ仏教をしようと思ったら
もう何とか知ってるんですね
あれ すごい迷惑なんです
結局何も知らない  なんかちょっとした情報が頭に入っちゃって
それでたまに私は腹が立って
本当にあなたはこういうことを知ってるんですかとことん責める場合あるんですね
その時は全然知らないということを本人に思い知らせますけど
それ認めたくない そう言われたって
私はこういうこういう本を読んで勉強したんだよと
じゃあどうしようもないんですよ
ですから この無差別にこの知識を積み込んでもらって
それは頭の中できちんと整理していない
例えば歌えるんだと 楽譜はいくらか読めるんだと
と言ったならば それだけのことでいて
音楽の世界を知り尽くしたわけじゃないんです
だから私にだったら まあ少々楽譜を読むのであって
カラオケではまあいくらかもう何何曲ぐらいは歌えるんだと
その場合はこういう風に歌えればうまくできるんだ
それぐらいの知識だよとしっかりした方があのもうもう状態が出てこないんですね
法華経は読んだんだけど
まあまあ こういうこういうことは分かったんだけど
こういうこういうところは全然わからないんだと
と言うならば大丈夫なんですね
法華経はいい加減に読んで
それで私は姿勢体ということはありましてと言った途端
ああ そんなことはわかります
私は知ってますと偉そうなことを言うんですね
それで話にならないんですね
ですから このいつでも人間問題を作っているのは
こういうこのもう知識残飯なんですよ
いろんな情報を入れるわ
入れるわ 入れるわ それは丁寧に整理しない
どこまで知って どこまで知らないかということは知らない
例えば 薬の場合は 今コンピューターにも入ってるんでしょうに
いろんな薬のどういう働きがありますか？どういう副作用
副作用あるかどうかね
もう入ってることは入ってますよ
それはちょっとした知識だけであって
だからといって自分の何か病気になった時は
じゃあ私はこの薬買ってこういうふうに飲みますよということは絶対できないんです
そこまでやっちゃうとお医者さんにもどうにもならないんですね
例えば注射の方法いろいろありますけど
それはイントラビーナスでするか
普通の体に注射するか
あと直接心臓に直接注射するかとかね
注射の種類もいろいろあるんです
そこで 自分の病気の場合は心臓に直接注射しなくちゃいけないんだと
知ったっても何の意味もない
自分でできますか？あんなことは
心臓に直接注射できるのはすごいプロのお医者さんだけなんですよ
ですから それはあ こういうことも世の中であるんだという知識だけで終わっていただければ大変結構なのに
どうにもならない状態になっているんですね
私の経験で言うならば
何も仏教の知識はなくて
仏教というのはブッダのブッダが教えたこと
ブッダというのは何者かと
それぐらいも知らない方々は抜群に頭が冴えてきて成長するんですよ
教えてあげたところで
正直にはこういうことはこういうことだからやってみようとかね
そこでもプロが来るんですね
何年経っても頭が悪いまんまで終わっちゃうんです
全然進まない そういう問題
我々にあるんです この知識残飯というのは
僕はわざわざ使っている言葉で
入れてそこで困ってるんですね
残飯だから それはまあ肥料
肥料に使えばいいし それを大事に思ったっていうのも結局草だけなんですよ
ですから この私たちは
こういう現代社会ではね
いろんなもう知識あって
それでかなり悩んだりする
だから余計な悩み 子供は学校に行ったらいろいろ子供の問題について知ってるでしょ
残飯知識がありますから
そこで悪いグループに入ったらどうしようか
学校でいじめられたらどうしようかとかね
登校拒否しちゃったらどうしようかどうか
まあ最初からもう悩んでるんですね
それでも子供を育てることは全くできない
最初からビクビクしているんだから
それでおかしいことに妊娠しちゃったら学校あるんです
正しく妊婦さんはどうすればいいかとか
どうすれば出産 出産の
またそういう学校というんですかの場合は
そういう教えてくれるとこがあったりして
まあ昔の人はそんなもの何もなくたって我々を産んでくれたんだけどね
その知識なければ子供を産めない
育てないというならば
人類がいないはずなんですけど
まあとにかくそういう知識あったりしちゃうと
まあもうかなり混乱状態になってしまっちゃうんですね
そこで教育は早くやれば早い方がいいやと勝手に決めちゃって
それで 1歳からも教えようとしている
そこで気が済まないで
お腹の中ででも教えてあげようとしている人々は世の中に確実にいるんですね
それで困るでしょうね
困るは 困るは困るは それで何が生まれてくるかって
不安 不安 不安だけ生まれてくるんですね
その人々にも私は言いたいのは
この知識残飯というのは決して悪いことじゃないんですよ
もういろんなことを知るのは面白いんだったら知ってもいいし
その場合はこういうことも世の中にあるんだという知識だけで結構で
それは役には立たないんです
ちょっとした遊びみたいに
ですから 別にあっちこっち新聞雑誌を読んで知識を入れたっていい
それは決して悪いことではなくて
それによって困らないようにしてほしいんです
で まあそれだったら問題ないだろうと思います
そこを 1つ 一応考えてみましょう
このあまり考えすぎ 知識あると考えることは全部妄想だけで
どうしよう どうしようと
そこからはこのどうしようもない不安が生まれてくるんです
ですから このどうしようもない不安が
この知識からかなり生まれてくる
いわゆる知識といっても
役に立つ仕事になる お金になる知識じゃないんです
この残飯ですね 例えば音楽家には音楽の知識ある
その人はそれで食べてるんだから
それは問題にならないんです
自分がその世界のプロだから
学校の先生は教えることのプロであって
その知識は決して問題にはならないんです
そういうことではなくて
まあ一応知っておかなくちゃなんとか不便ということで得られる知識はたまに問題になる
ですから この知っておかなくちゃなんとか不便というものはそれぐらいでしてほしい
そこでこのなんとか不安というのは
また出てくるのは この前も言ったように
このもちろん頭が悪いからと言ったでしょ
頭が悪いと言ったのは
知識は積み込んじゃって
頭の中混乱状態になっている
ですから 僕は悪いと言ったんですね
別に他の意味ではなくて
私は頭がいいというのは知識あるないことに関係なく
自分がしっかりと明確に自分の世界で生きていられるかないかという生きる知恵なんですね
知識っていうことではなくて
だから このいつでもしっかりと物事を判断できるような心だけは必要なんです
それからの問題 じゃあ
少々次にこの仏教の世界に入って考えてみましょう
人間っていうのは まあ一番この非合理的な動物ですから
あの事実は認めたくない
事実に逆らいたいという気持ちがあるんですね
嘘だったら万々歳でOKだと受け入れるんですね
ですから 我々は嘘の世界で大変喜びを感じる
真実の世界で居心地がなんか悪くなってしまっちゃうんです
そう なんかわからない言葉なんですね
それ違うでしょと思うでしょ
もしかすると人間こそ合理的ではないかと
そうでもないんです 人間こそ非合理的な人
生命はいないんです で
これなんでこれ言ったんですかというと
世の中のものっていうのはいつでも変化して消えていく
どんな状態もそのままあるということはないんです
人間がそれは嫌なんです
嫌と言ったっても 変化するものは変化するんだから
それで困ってしまっちゃう
それで不安が生まれていく
このなんとか不安 大体そういうところから生まれてくる
例えば 若い人がいる 若くて美しいと
その若くて美しいということは瞬間のことで
みるみるうちに消えてしまうんです
なぜならば この体はずっと新しい物質は入って
古い物質は出ていく 体は止まっても
もらわもらいません ずっとそういうふうに体が変化している
そこで自分が鏡で自分の体を見たところで
あ 綺麗だと そこで この綺麗な状態がずっとそのまんまであって欲しがっちゃう
あって欲しがるんだけど
毎日 1日経っちゃうんですね
カレンダーがもう 1枚1枚出ていっちゃうんだから
そこで二十歳の人は 21歳にもなるし
21歳は 23になっちゃうし
それで強烈に不安が生まれてくるんです
いろいろあるんです 例えば女性の場合は 23
5 4 6 7 8になっちゃうとかなり不安を感じちゃうし
それ 30ぐらいになっちゃうと強烈になるんです
ある不安は正しいんです
例えば 30歳になってもまだ結婚していないんだと
そうするともう早く結婚しなくちゃということになっちゃうんですね
相手見つかるのは難しいし
年取ったら子供を産むのは難しいし
結婚したところで子供がないと家族ではないんだから
ですから どうしようかと
その不安は僕は合理的だと思いますよ
ちょっと落ち着きがなくなっちゃって
混乱状態になっちゃって
それはいくらか合理的
なぜならば その人がいくら世間にごまかししたって
私はまだまだ二十歳ですよ
ああだこうだとか 心の中ではそうじゃないんだと
あと 5年以内に結婚しなかったら
もう大変なことになるんだよという
この強烈に自分の体が
このバイオ時計がもう動いているということはわかっているんですね
無常であると だから やることは早く手を打たなきゃいけないんだと
で そこまで合理的な不安なんです
でも 不安は合理的に持っちゃうと
すぐ解決方法出てくる
そこで問題は ただ困っちゃう
ただ悩んじゃう 悩んじゃうと
体中この悩みの波動が出ていて
美しさはすごく消えちゃって
なんか恐ろしい顔になっちゃうんですよ
そこで相手を見つかるところが
いつも相手に逃げられると
というふうなことになってしまっちゃうんですね
ですから そういう合理的な悩みが生まれた時でも
まあそういうことだから
あまりまあ適当にもう誰でもいいんだからという感じで
まあ早く相手を見つかって
まあ落ち着いた方がいいんではないかと
もうちょっと冷静に考えちゃうと
心が落ち着いている 心が落ち着いていると
男の人には好かれる ああ
あの人 すごい落ち着いている人だと
その人だったら 一生にその人と一緒にいても問題ないんだと
というふうな気持ちになって
すぐ相手が見つかる ある女性の方が同じ質問を私に聞いたんです
ものすごく悩んでいて
で そう説明したら 私はまあ同じ問題でね
年も年で言われたらまあ大変だと
で 聞いたら なかなかあなたの周りに相手が誰かいないんですか？って言ったら
自分の仕事環境では誰もいないんだと
だからさらに困っているんだと
それは別に合理的な悩みだからね
それで私はこう言ったんですね
この相手探そうとかね
早く結婚しようとかね
そんなものを忘れてくださいと
そんなもの全部忘れて
あんた楽しく楽にね そんなことは運命に任せちゃってね
もしふさわしい相手がいれば
その時現れるんだからね
もうリラックスしてくださいと
そんなに年どうこうだと言ったって
あんたは結構若くて まあ結構綺麗ですよと
ですから まあ楽しく楽にリラックスして 2
3週間やってみてください
それ全部忘れてくださいと
この運命の人がいるならば
確実に来ますから大丈夫やと言ってリラックスさせてあげたんです
まだまだあなたの時期ではないんだと
言ったら ああそう 私の時期ではない
その時期になったらそううまくいくんだと
と本人が決めちゃって
もうリラックスしちゃったんですね
2 3週間経ったところでまた会いに来て
実は相手は見つかりましたと
で そんなもんなんですよ
で 私はどうせ知ってるんだから
それは自分の関係の周りのね
誰かですから いまだにそのスイッチを入れなかったんですね
こちらはもうとにかく誰か誰でもいいんだから
男一人捕まろうという気持ちでしょうね
そうすると男から見れば鬼に見えちゃうんですよ
この人と喋ったら危ないんだと
僕はそれを解決してあげたんですね
それで落ち着いて まあ時期が来たらもう人が現れるだろうという気持ちで落ち着いたところで
周りにいた一人の人がもう話しかけてきて
どうですかと だからそういうふうに合理的な悩み
合理的な不安の場合も
落ち着いてさえいれば
すぐもう問題 答えが出てくる
それはそこは話を置いておいて
非合理的な悩み 例えばとにかく若くていたいとかね
男性の場合はとにかくすごい元気で
もう力強くてずっといたいとかね
あるいは会社の場合はずっと儲かっぱな
儲かりっぱなしでやりたいとかね
会社は大きくするのはもうどこまででも大きくしてやるぞとかね
そういうふうな欲望希望が出てくる
で そういうのは全部非合理的
全部非合理的 法則に逆らっているもので
それでなんとか不安が生まれてくる
例えば 儲かりっぱなしというのは成り立たないことで
自分が勝手に儲かっているわけじゃなくて
社会システムの中で儲かれるような条件が揃っているだけ
ですから このシステムは少々条件を変えれば儲かる率が減ったり増えたりはする
それを理解してほしいんですね
それは理解しないで もうさらに儲かりたい
さらに儲かりたい ただそれだけ
若い人は若いのはいいんだけど
綺麗でもいいんだけど
ずっと 80歳に  90歳に
120歳になったっても
二十歳の若さでいようと思うのは非合理的なんですね
それに頑張っちゃうと
自分すっごい精神的な混乱を味わわなくちゃいけない
なぜならば どう頑張っても年は取るわ
体がもう年取ってするわ
若さが消えていくわ その上それ認めたくない
で 必死でありとあらゆる努力をする
すればするほど失敗を味わう
それで その不安はすべてのものに広げてしまっちゃう
家庭は不安 社会は不安
人間は不安 ああだこうだとかね
全く落ち着くが消えてしまう
ですから この我々の非合理的な欲望
捨ててほしい 人間 非合理的で法則に逆らおうとする
会社儲かってもずっと儲かるわけじゃない
会社大きくするのはできるんだけど
どこまでも大きくすることは不可能なんです
健康な体はありがたいんだけど
健康はずっとあるわけじゃないんです
体力はありがたいんだけど
ずっとその体力でいられるわけじゃないんです
ですから 世の中っていうのはそんなもんだと理解して落ち着く
そうするとまた不安が消えてしまう
理解して落ち着く よく覚えてください
ですから 私は言うのは
自分が綺麗で生まれたならば
それはありがたいことで
よくありがたくて綺麗な体で生まれたのではないかと
まあ幸福を感じればよろしい
今は綺麗ですけどね 20歳二十歳になるわ
30歳になるわ  40歳になるわ
その時その年にふさわしい生き方でいいんじゃ
ないかと そうするといつでも可愛いんですよ
二十歳は二十歳なりに可愛いし
三十歳は三十歳に年にふさわしく可愛いし
三十歳の人は二十歳の女の子みたいないろんなことをやっちゃうと
可愛いどころかもうすごい気持ち悪い
それで六十歳になったっても
まあ三十歳みたいなお化粧をして服装を着て
それにまあ二十歳ぐらいのアクセサリーいっぱいつけちゃっていると
まあどうかなと思いますけどね
例えば この若い人は短い服なんか着ていたっても
すごく綺麗に目に映るんですよ
そこで六十歳の人もものすごい短いスカートなんか着て歩いたりすると
もう男性は丁寧だから言わないんだけど
あれすごい気持ち悪いんです
でも そういうお年の方々は
自分の体にちゃんとした
この年にふさわしい服装を着ていると
ものすごい上品に 夫人
義夫人というんですか
そういう風に見えるんですね
素晴らしい方ですよと
そういうことは 自分がこの法則に逆らわないで
法則に沿う 法則に従う
そうするといつでも OK なんです
例えば すごくばあちゃんになったと
もう体は骨だけで もう皮膚は全部しわしわしわだらけで
でもものすごい可愛いんですよ
それも決して可愛くないわけじゃないんです
そこでもう八十歳 九十歳になったばあちゃんがばあちゃんらしく生きていると
僕はあれほど可愛い人はないですと思いますよ
私個人的な好みで言えば
僕はその八十歳 九十歳のばあちゃんだったら
ものすごい気持ちよく喋るんです
なんかすごいこちらまで落ち着いてくるんですよ
でも その人は歳はちょっと狂っている場合はもう逃げるんです
ですから このこの九十歳になって百歳になっても
もうガタガタ体のもう骨だけにもう全部筋肉が消えちゃって
もうもうしわと骨しか何も残ってないぐらいになっても
その可愛いんですよ 堂々と私は今百十九歳よとかなんとか言ってくれて
もうみんなとね 孫たちやらひ孫たちやらね
それなりにも遊んだりくれたりすると
みんな寄ってくるし もう可愛いんです
ですから 我々は法則に逆らうと可愛くもないし
限りない不安が生まれてくるし
すごい問題が作って みんなに嫌われて不幸になる
法則に沿って生きていると
いつでもみんなとすごくうまくいくんです
それだけじゃなく 自分の体もいつでもうまく持ち運べることはできるんです
年取ったところで 男性の場合もあんまり早く体は動かせない
それで自分の年にふさわしい動き方をするとかね
ある女性の方に私はこの杖を使ってくださいと言ったんです
怒られたんです ものすごい背が高くて
すごい歳で で 結構もうすごい上品な形の人でしたけど
で よくこけるみたいで
こけちゃったら どこかで骨を骨を折っちゃったところで
またもうベッドになって
また半年間とかね それ終わったらまた堂々と階段上ったり
あっち行ったりこっち行ったりするし
そこですごい元気で それその分すごい素晴らしいんですよ
幸福なんですけど このわがまま
頑固さで もうみんな心配して
だからみんなに心配生まれる
自分がどこかで時計狂ってるんですね
元気だから 健康的だから
すごい体格はよろしいんだから
いつでもそんな感じで生きていきたがっちゃうんです
でも 年も年だから ものすごい背が高い
骨組みを筋肉にはなかなかコントロールできないんです
で 私は言ったのは あなたはよく外国旅行でもあっちこっちするでしょ
ですから ものすごいおしゃれでオシャレな杖
イギリスいっぱいありますからね
イギリス人が若くたっても杖使ってるでしょうに
あれはオシャレなんですね
ですから まあオシャレで杖一つ使えば
まあちょっと不安な時はそれ押せばいいでしょうしと
そうすると大丈夫です
それだけで問題解決するでしょ
みんな家族の不安が消えるんだと
あなたもこけないし あなたの自由もあるし
どこでも歩けるし それに怒られたんですね
だからなぜ怒られたかというと
やっぱり自分が若い時と同じく走り回ることができると思っているんですね
そこでできるわけじゃないし
結局みんなに迷惑し 自分に対しても
これよく元気な人にとってはもう 3ヶ月間ベッドにもう骨折れちゃっているということは
また大変苦痛なんですよ
それ 何一つもないんですね
スウィッチだけ使ったならば
ですから 我々はこの法則に逆らうと
いろんな不幸に出会うし
みんなに迷惑かけるし
本人も ものすごい不安で生きてなくちゃいけない
ですから 最終的に言いたいのは
病気になればそれでいいんじゃないかと
人はどうせ病気になる
年取ればそれで別にどうってことないでしょうに
我々のもう設計図決まってるんだから
生きている日 生まれた日からずっと年取ることを決まってるんだから
それに逆らう必要はないし
どんどん体が弱くなっていく
それに逆らおうとする必要ない
弱くなると それに従ってそれなりにふさわしい生活すればいいと
今年儲けても来年儲からないかもしれませんし
それにいちいち混乱する必要はないし
そういうふうに法則を理解すること
仏教で言っているこの無常の論理ですか
それはしっかりと身について生きていられることは不安をなくす方法なんですね
ですから 例えば自分の子供は 15
6歳になってくると まあ男であろうが女であろうが
まあ随分混乱して もう反抗する
親に逆らう それで困ったり悩んだり
せっかく自分の髪の毛がさっさと白くなってしまったりするんですね
そういう必要ないんです
それはすごい楽しく 反抗時期になったよと楽しく見ればいいんです
認めてあげればいいんです
それで問題解決する 子供っていうのはどうせ親に当たって成長するんだから
親は何かかの なんて言いますか
親っていうのは本当にかわいそうな存在であり
ボクシングなんか練習するとサンドバッグですか
ありますね それサンドバッグに一生懸命ぶん殴って
ぶん殴って ぶん殴って練習するんですよ
サンドバッグはいつでも殴り返しはしないんです
もう思い存分殴ってくださいと
それでやがてボクサー
ボクサーになっちゃうんですね
両親というのはそのサンドバッグみたいなもんなんですよ
子供は大人になるために
まず誰にぶつかるかというと
自分の両親にぶつかってみるんです
ですから 今までいい子でしたけど
なんか急にとんでもない悪い子になったよ
そんなことないんですよ
別に小さい時 いいこといい人であったわけでもないし
大人になって悪い子になったわけでもないんです
その年にふさわしい態度をとっているだけ
それでわがままで乱暴で大人になりたいんですね
言ったっても 社会人にわがまま乱暴しちゃったらひどい目に遭うでしょうに
殴り返すでしょうに それで親に向かって言いたい放題のことを言ったりとか
わがまま言ったりとか
逆らってみたりとかする
それ自分が の感じで それは受け止める
受け止めると 子供はそれなりに成長して立派な社会人になると
それに逆らおうとする
小さい時と同じく 何でも言ってくれる
聞いてくれる子供になってほしいでしょ
というのは精神的な病気
完全に従っちゃうんですね
二十歳になっても 三十歳になっても
混ぜ込んで いて欲しがっちゃうんですね
そこは良くないと ですから
我々はだいたいこの法則を客観的に見て
物事は変化する 子供は大きくなる
家を出て行っちゃう 会社もずっとその状態にはいるわけじゃないし
会社でバリバリ仕事をしても
年取っていくと若者は入ってきて
元気な連中が入ってきて
自分がどんどんどんどん窓の方にまあいくようになっていくとかね
それは別になんと何のことなくクールな心でいると
自分の命は大丈夫なんです
そろそろそうなったら
これからリストラになるかもしれません
クビになるかもしれません
どうしようかと困っちゃうと
確実にリストラになってしまっちゃうんです
落ち着いているとそうはならないんです
ですから また私は話に戻ってあげますけど
海に落ちたら浮いてみてください
それだけですよと 逆らうな
逆らったら死ぬんだと
そういう法則で生きていれば
すべての不安が消えると思います
でまあ それから関係ない話なんですけど
この病気と不安という関係なんですけど
で まあ仏教には全然関係ない話ですよ
仏教でいうのは人は病気になるんだと
これは止められませんと
それで仏教を勉強してどうすれば病気治りますかと聞くんですね
で 私の答えはお医者さんに頼みみて聞いてみてくださいと
で 仏教をやって瞑想して病気治してほしいというならば
それはまあ ちょっともう真理にはもう
ちょっとね まあおかしいんです
仏教っていうのは 人は病気になる
年は取る すべてのものはなくなる
使うものは何もない それに悟ってくださいということだから
で 僕らにどうやればずっと商売繁盛できるかと
どうやればずっと永遠に若さでいられるんですか？どうやれば死なないで永遠
永遠の命を得られるんですかと
どうやれば病気にならないかというと聞くんだからね
そこで正直にはそんなことないと言わなくちゃいけない
インチキ宗教になったら
ちゃんとそうそう この宗教をやれば病気にならないんだ
家庭は円満になるんだ
商売繁盛するんだと言うんです
それはもうインチキなんです
僕は元気になってほしいんです
こういうインチキのところに行く
インチキの教えに 同じ浄土真仏教であろうとも
もしそういう元気になることや病気治ることなんとか言っちゃえば
その分もう確実にインチキなんですね
ですから そういうところに行くということは
その本人がものすごい精神的に不安で弱くて
人間らしくないということなんです
人間らしくない だからまあ
なんとか病気治してくれるのではないかと
病気治してくれる何か超能力でもないんではないかと
もう探したりする それよりはしっかりと生きていた方がいいんです
人間らしくなった方がいいんです
で 宗教でそんなことは回復してくれるかどうかはちょっとわからない
で 人々は弱くて 誰かにすがりたくて頼りたくもいる場合は
まあそういう誰かがそういうインチキのシステムを作っちゃうと
そこで商売っていうのは成り立つんですね
そこで  それはまあ 商売目的である宗教になってしまっちゃう
仏教は全くその世界ではないんです
どのようにおっしゃっていますかというと
仏教は有名になるために勉強するなと
知識人になって人々と競争するために使うなと
そういう御利益のために勉強するなと
断られているんです 仏教っていうのは
いっそでも心をサンワラったん
心をコントロールするために
落ち着かせてもらうために
パーリ語でサンワラったんと言うんです
もし欲しい方々はメモを書いておいてください SA SNSAM
と書いて下に点を入れてください
それさんではなくてサンと読むんです
サン それからV V このビクトリーのV B
ではなくてVARAARA
そうそう RA それからT2つ
それからH それからEHの次E
それからMMの下に点一つ入れる
それではサンワラッタンと読むんです
サンワラッタン で またすすり言います SAMVARATTAM
サンワラッタン サンワラッタンというのは自分のコントロールするために
自分を落ち着くためという意味なんです
FOR THE SELF CONTROLという意味なんです
次の目的はパハナッタンという言葉なんです
パハナッタンすすりはPAH A
その A の上に小さな棒を引いておくんです
ハイフン A の頭に上にパハと読むんです
長いんです それからNA TTT2
つHA M 下に点  M の下に点
もう一回言います PAHA
その A の上に小さな棒 NATTHAM
下に点と読み方はパハナッタンパハナッタン
パハナッタンというのはもう
執着の反対 無執着のために捨て去るために
ものに物事にとらわれなく
物事から解脱解放するためにという意味なんです
パハナッタン ああ 一応その目的なんですね
仏教目的は 御利益のためっていうことはなかなかないんですけどね
でも 仏教を実践する人々は大変幸福で生きていられるんだとということは言ってるんです
確実に幸福になります
それは御利益というかどうかはわからない
いわゆる人間の苦しみも不安も全部消えますから
合理的に生きていると
それは幸福なんです だからといって年取ることをやめてもらったとか
そんな気持ち悪い話は言わない
病気になることをやめてもらったとかね
それだったら世の中のみんな寺は上座部仏教を信じるようになりますけどね
上座部仏教の国々でもかなり病院いっぱいありますよ
みんな病気になっちゃうし
日本より早く死んじゃうし
寿命はそんなに長くないんです
でも誰一人仏教を捨てたわけじゃないんです
だからそういう目的は
ちょっとバカバカらしいんですよ
それすごい もう病 それは病気なんですよ
病気を治すためにとか思うこと自体が
で その代わりにこれは言いたいんですね
なぜ人間が病気になるかと
病気になるということは
我々はずっと心で悩みがあって
悩みがあって 心を燃やしてるんですね
心じゃなくて体を 悩みっていうのは猛烈な炎のようなものなんです
わけもなく悩む 悩む 悩む
困る 困る 困ると その困ると心からすごい炎のような波動が出てきて
全部細胞がものすごく痛めるんですよ
なんかこの墨にかけたような感じなんですね
全部もう痛めちゃうんですね
焼き魚状態なんですよ
我々の体が 炎が心から生まれてくるんです
ですから 自分の体から生まれてくる悩みという炎によって
体がもう痛めて痛めていくんですね
ですから どうせ想像以上に人間が病気になる
年取る 本当のところは経典にこういうことあるんですね
昔々 人間っていうのは 8万4000年とか
寿命は長かったとかね
だから それは嘘だろうと思っちゃうでしょ
人の寿命 8万4000年って何ですか？と
ありっこはないんだと
でもあり得るんです 何のことなく
どういうことかというと
我々の DNA なんかはそんな早く死ぬようにプログラムされてないんです
我々はやってる余計なことによって
DNA から出てくる RNA となんとかやりますからね
そういうのは変なものができちゃって
早く早くがんになったり
病気になったり 心臓が悪くなったりして
早く死んでしまっちゃうんです
ですから 心の悩みさえなければ
じわじわと我々の寿命は延びる
そこで病気な体では伸びませんよ
ですから 健康な体と長生き
両方ついてくるんです
病気な人は早く死ぬっていうことはわかってるんだからね
ですから 私たちが心で余計に悩んだり悩んだりするんだからこそ
病気になってしまう それは医学的にみんな知ってるし
あんまりにも困ったりすると胃が荒れちゃうし
胃酸は胃は胃酸はものすごく出ちゃうし
いろんな臓器がいきなりおかしくなっちゃって活動し始めちゃうでしょうに
体の中 いろんな恐ろしいものはいっぱいあるし
例えば胃の中の液体に胃そのものも溶かすことできますよ
肉溶かしちゃいますから
ちょっと間違ったら自分の胃は自分で食べてしまう恐れがあるんですね
で 白血球とかなんとかとかね
ものすごい恐ろしいって
もうものは見たらすぐ食べてしまっちゃうでしょうね
ちょっと頭がおかしくなっちゃったら
自分の体を食べてしまっちゃうでしょうね
例えば 体の糖分をコントロールするためにインスリン丁寧に出てくる
ちょっと間違ったら インスリンほんのわずかでも出過ぎちゃった
なっちゃったら ほんの微細な量なんですけど
すぐ意識不明になってしまっちゃうんですよ
だから我々はこんなもう気をつけなくちゃいけないんですよ
大変なシステムを持ってるんです
その上悩んだりしちゃうと
どこかで機能がおかしくなっちゃうんです
おかしくなっちゃったら機能おかしくなっちゃって
それで体のシステムのバランスが崩れてしまう
で ゆっくりゆっくり悩んじゃうと
ゆっくりゆっくりと体が壊れてしまうんですね
それである日 いきなりがんになったんだと
いきなりがんになったわけじゃなくて
自分がずっと生きてきた生き方によって
きちんと順番でがんになっただけなんです
去年まですごい元気でいたんだけど
もういきなり そんなことはないんです
そういうことで落ち着いてみましょう
いつでも落ち着いてリラックスして
どんな問題にもめげないで
問題ぶつけ問題にぶつけようではなくて
すごい鋭く巧みに問題に付き合って
避ける時は避ける 無視する問題は無視する
解決する問題は解決する
でも自分が悩んだりはしない
そういう風にしちゃうと
我々の病気はほとんど出てこない
そこで この 8万4000年ぐらい生命寿命があったという時期で
お釈迦様はこう言うんですね
その当時の人々がものすごく落ち着いていたんだと
混乱状態ではなかったんだと
殺生したり 泥棒したり
よく知らない行為をしたり
嘘をついて人を騙したりとか
そういうややこしい状態はなかったんだと
みんな仲良く兄弟みたいに人を兄弟だから騙す必要ないでしょうに
一番よく言うのは この精神的な問題
欲と怒り それはパーリ語でアビジャとヴィーパードと言うんです
ちょっと綴りは難しいんですけど
アビジャっていうのはABHI ABHIJJHA ABHIJJHA
アビジャ 最後のAは長く伸び伸び伸ばすんです A
の頭の上に棒引けばいい
アビジャ 次の言葉はヴィーパード
ヴィーはヴィー ヴィーワイ
ヴィーワイエー それでAは長い
それからPA またそのAも長い
それからDA ヴィーパード
もう一度言います ヴィーワイエー
ピーエーディーエー で
ヴィーパードと言うんです
アビジャっていうのは
この精神的にこの原因にも原因もない怒り
とにかく怒っている とにかくもう私はそれは余計な怒りと訳しますけどね
とにかくいるでしょ？なんか怒りの性格も戦わなくちゃ
もういられない もうじっとしていられない
とにかく頑張ろうではないかとか
もう戦ってやろうとかね
というなんか必死に勢いで行動する
すごい精神的な落ち着きがないんです
それは余計な怒りと言うんです
なぜ余計な怒りと言うな
言うというとこういうこと
で 子供は 例えばとんでもない悪いことをしちゃったと
それで母が怒る お父さんが怒る
それは余計な怒りじゃないんです
原因があって怒っただけ
そこで人がなんか自分を騙しちゃったと
そこで自分がその人に対して怒ったと
それは余計な怒りではなくて
まあわかりやすい怒り
人にバカにされちゃったんだと
それでカッとなったと
それはもうわかりやすいんですね
そういう怒りじゃなくて
ただ怒っている いるでしょ
たまにある人々はいつでも物事を批判するは批判するは批判するは
これはこうではない あれはこうではない
こうではない ああではないとかね
そういうのを精神的な問題なんですね
評論家みたいに何でも評論することとかね
すごく怒りがあって この皆様の周りの中でも
これみんなに嫌われてる性格ある人々っていうのは
よくあ おせっかい よくおせっかいしたくなる
説教をしたくなる みんな偉そうに
よく探すと 心の中でいつでもこの人は元気で楽しくいるのは嫌なんですね
会社でみんなものすごくニコニコお互いにからかったり
冗談言ったりして仕事をしていると
もう社長やら部長やら課長やら何者でもいいんだけど
来ちゃったらみんなきちんとなったりとかするんですね
それはもうすごい あんたしっかりやりなさいとか言われるんだからなんです
真面目にやりなさいとかね
それは余計な怒り  そういう性格があると危ない
その人々は確実にもう病気になってしまう
次にあるのは余計な欲
あ あ すいません もしかすると私はこの言葉逆に言った
余計な怒りはアビジャー
もし間違ったらば直してください
また間違った ちょっと待ってください
頭整理します ヴィャーパでは余計な怒り
ヴィャーパでは余計な怒り
今はもうしっかりしています
私の頭も ヴィャーパでは余計な怒り
アビジャーは余計な欲
で アビジャー 余計な欲ありますよ
それでも欲 世の中にありますよ
余計な欲 きりがない欲
それで精神的に細胞はもう燃えてしまっちゃうんです
で 大体この仕事をする時は皆様知ってるでしょうに
この会社なんかは余計な欲でやってるんですね
いくら儲けても足らない
どんな会社の経済状態を聞いたには
やっぱり景気が悪いんだ
景気が悪いんだと 聞いたら景気が悪いんだと
儲かっても全然儲かってないんだと
それだったら会社倒産してるはずでしょうに
ということは 儲かっていたっても足りません
足りませんと ということなんですね
ちょっと円の値段がちょっと変わっちゃったら
あ 大変だ 大変だと おかしいことは
円の値段が上がると大変だ
大変だと言うんですね
下がるとまた大変だ 大変だ
どっちですかね それで経済学者だと自分で名乗ってるんですね
例えばこの余計な怒られても
例えばこのあの円の価値が上がっちゃって
上がっちゃったところで
それで一部は損するんですね
一部は損する 仕事している
それだけ取って大変だ
大変だ どれこれぐらい
これぐらい 何億円 何億円
何億円も もう損しました
損しましたとと言ったって
また一部は儲かってるでしょうに
それは全く言わない 計算
経済学に判断するために使おうともしない
それで円が下がっちゃうと
下がっちゃうと抜群に儲かる連中は儲かってるんでしょうに
それは無視と損している人々のことだけ取って
もう喋るは喋るは 何の経済学でもないんで
そんなことは それで国は良くなるわけでもないんですね
それで私に見えるのは
この人々は余計な欲だけ衝動にしてるんではないかと
それでその国をダメにしているんではないかと
ですから 我々はそういう余計な欲の社会に生きてるんですよ
いくらあっても足れないと
だから小さな会社作ってもいいんだけど
まあこれぐらい儲ければいいんではないかと
どこかでちょっとしたこのリミットを決めておけばいいのに
私には死ぬまで生きていられるためには
まあこれぐらいお金収入あればいいやと
そういうふうにリミットを作ればいいし
ですから その場合は欲捨てるということではなくて
この精神的に異常 病気
病的な欲捨てる 病的な怒り捨てる
捨てるというんです この4000
8万4000年とうの遠い時代の場合は
そのアビジャーとヴィャーパードはなかったんだと
その人々は 落ち着いていたんだということなんですね
わかりやすい例を申し上げます
例えば余計な欲の場合は
例えば女性二人がいるとしましょう
それで一人の女性がかなりの大きなダイヤの指輪をつけているんだと
あるいはダイヤのネックレスをつけているんだ
それはもうダイヤのネックレス
指輪も何千万ですからね
それでもう一人の女性はもう全然アクセサリーつけてないとか
あるいはまあせいぜい 10万円ぐらいの指輪をつけているんだと
で 隣の指輪を見ると すごい高価なものをつけているんですねと
あ これはこの間旦那さんからもらったよと言ったかもしれません
あ よかったんではないかと思えば
それで終わるでしょ 問題は
やっぱり私もこういう指輪あった方がいいなと思うと
ものすごく細胞が燃え始めちゃうんです
私もいいなと思ったっても
それは指輪っていうのは収入の問題だから
収入がなければ買えないんだから
そんなことは放っておけばいいんです
こんな金属なんか体に付けなくたってもどうでもいいんだから
体には別に だからまあまああなたはすごいいいですねとかね
あ よかったんですねとか
それでその人を褒めて
それでは私には関係ないんだと
ある人は高級外車に乗っているかもしれません
自分が小さな軽自動車に乗っているかもしれませんし
それで 2人は友達 それでいいんじゃないんですか？私にはこんな車は面倒できません
お金もない だから私には関係ない
たまに高級車に乗りたく乗りたいと気持ちがあったら
ちょっと貸してくれませんか？と言って貸してもらっても
それは別に構いません
例えば 2番 2番目の奥さんも
高価な指輪をちょっとつけてみたいなと思ったら
ちょっと私のをちょっとつけてくれませんか？と言ってもらって
やっぱりいいですねとか褒めて返してあげれば
二人とも気持ちいいんだから
貸してあげた人も気持ちいいし
もうつけてもらった人も気持ちいいし
男の場合は自分には抜群に高価ななんとかなんとか車ありますね
買えないほどの値段のフェラーリとかなんとか
そういう車に乗りたい気持ちはあるかもしれませんけど
ない場合はそういう友達がいるならばね
1時間でいいんだから
ちょっと貸してくれませんか？とかね
貸してもらって 1時間ぐらい乗ってみて
はい どうぞ ありがとうございましたと
それぐらいでいいんですよ
余計な欲さえなければ
そうすると 貸してあげた人にも立場がいいんですね
ほら どうですかとかね
私の車という風に その人も気持ちいいし
貸してもらった人も あの人は何のことなく
あんな高価な車ね 貸してくれたんだから
ああ よかったな やっぱり高級車は居心地
乗り心地はいいやとかね
自分でも体験があるし
ですから 余計な欲っていうのはそういうところで現れるんですよ
やっぱり私にもあればいいんじゃないかと
それでもお金がない そうすると頭に悪い知恵が働くんでしょうね
悩むか 会社のお金を横領するか
賄賂を取るするか どっちかになってしまっちゃうんですね
盗むかどっちかと それで不幸になってしまっちゃうんですね
それで寿命は短くなる
ですから アビッジャーとウェーパードだけ捨てれば
人は病気にならない 寿命は延びる
DNA にはもう 8 万年でも生きていられるぐらいのすごいプログラムはできているんです
そういうことで 悩めば病気になる
じゃあ悩まないためにどうすればいいかというと
落ち着くこと 落ち着くこと
いつでもクリアな日本
カタカナでどういうふうに発音しますかね
クリアマインド キキララすごくクリア
心で生活する どんな問題あろうとも
びくともしないと たとえ地震があっても
家は火事になっても 自分の誰か
うちの人が事故に遭って急に死んだと聞いても
心だけは落ち着いてますと
そうするとどんな問題にもきちんと対応できるんだと
問題に対応できるならば
それは抜群な幸福であると
対応できない場合は不幸だと
ですから クリアな心 落ち着いた心というのは
決して感情のない心というわけじゃないんです
つまらない心というわけじゃないんです
それこそ素晴らしい心なんです
混乱の心で何一つもできないんです
自分にも迷惑 他人にも迷惑
そういうことでもう悩みの解決方法っていうのは
落ち着いている心で きれいな心でいることで
それを育てましょうということなんですね
ですから たとえ地震が起きても
たとえ自分の家が火事になっても
たとえ自分の身内の人が急に事故でも崩れ
死んだと話聞いたっても
自分の身内の人々は 家族の人々は外国旅行してたけど
その飛行機はまあ落ちたんですよと聞いても
冷静な心でいて 次にやるべきことはやりますと
ということで 生きていられれば
それぐらいのしっかりした心で
で 終わりと思います すべての幸福を得られると思います
どうもありがとうございました